the Joe Rogan experience the cool thing
about the news cycle is waiting for hope
like waiting for like to get online and
get excited and go oh breakthrough today
or but that's why I like you god damn
man once the [ __ ] goes sideways that's
when you need a really good leader you
really do
yeah you need someone who is honest when
all the [ __ ] goes away when
everyone's worried about an invisible
monster that wants to kill your grandma
what's a sneak into her lungs and shut
them down when people are worried about
that kind of [ __ ] you really want
someone who has their character and
order you know and this is this is one
of the things that we should really take
deeply into consideration when we talk
about someone being a president or any
any politician anyone who's a leader how
are they how do they gonna react when
[ __ ] goes sideways how are they gonna
keep it together are they gonna make you
feel good about this the reality of this
world are they gonna just freak you out
with [ __ ] are they're gonna make you
feel less connected to it because you
know that their words are not honest and
that they're not accurate they're not
they're not heartfelt it's just spitting
out [ __ ] and you're like [ __ ] this
goddamn car is going sideways down the
highway and no one knows what to do
that's why we need to vote for the ROC
I'd vote for him San Andreas find him
100% I would I'm all in for the ROC as
good as he is about everything else in
life he'd be great a president but no
one should be President yeah but the ROC
could like what you need is a figurehead
to let you know how today is gonna work
out yeah like you said those
inspirational speeches mean a lot yeah
and and the ROC could give us every
morning from the iron jungle just like
guys big day legs hey listen the
economy's doing good yeah but right now
everyone loves the rock if he became
president 40% of the people would
immediately start hating him no yes
unify the country impossible can't be
done we love it
all of the notes in the rocks crash hmm
there just be me and talk about how
dummy is it doesn't read it doesn't do
this yeah he's got biceps say bunch of
mean [ __ ] to him and then a tribute to
his decisions what the economy is doing
and what this is doing and that I like
that why would he do that you just keep
doing Jumanji movies and everybody loves
them
[Applause]